just a while so what do you make of the
foil part against you well I think it's
very sad we're supposed to be here this
week to fight Boris Johnson to outline
our positive vision for the country in
the general election and I think it's
been undermined on day one and I'm
particularly disappointed with John
Landsman the boss of momentum because I
think he's not just them behind me the
party and frankly I think he's
undermined the momentum delegates that
are here this week because they want to
talk about positive alternative for the
country as well do you think Jeremy
Corbyn knew about this plot last night I
don't know what Jeremy knew and didn't
know but do you think this is the end of
it well I hope it is because you know
we're just for the party conferences
voting on rule changes now and I want
this week to be the most positive week
we can have I want us to unify our ways
to talk about what our vision for the
country during and after a general
election it but that's gone hasn't it
that opportunity is gone well we've had
a bad start to our conference I can't do
anything about that but I can say to
people I hope we can come together for
the right what's your message to Jeremy
Corbyn them speak to Jeremy every day
but you know the both of us will want to
reunite the conference after what has
been frankly a quite ridiculous start
and totally unnecessary worry that it
might not be now sorry Tom do worry
there might not be now that they might
come for you in a year's time well I've
only just walked out of the of the
station so I don't know what what's
ahead of me in the way do I feel safe
well with all you lovely journalists
around I feel perfectly safe but let's
see how the delegates fare when I get
there do you think this is about
stopping you being acting leader well
actually it was the chair that stopped
the motion being taken so actually the
person that did stop this is Wendy
Nichol but I'm very grateful for
Jeremy's stable in a day and I just hope
we can unify around a positive vision
for the country for the rest of the way
I think it says there are some people
who don't think clear-headed Lee who
risk us having a transformative
government by playing sectarian games
and I put John Landsman in that category
and I just think it's very sad because I
think he's undermined himself and is and
then the members of his organization
many of whom have been in touch with me
today to say they were not consulted
when he when he did that and they were
very disappointed with him personally so
but you know that's politics and I've
been around a long time and I want us to
reunite now there is a real interest for
millions of the already suffered from a
decade of austerity who want change in
this country and you know we're big
enough to put away our differences and
well I am disappointed because I hoped
that we could unite this week and I'm
still hoping you can and that's what I'm
hoping to do whether I can get through
these cameras can you think of another
gap I always forget
[Applause]